show me one command anywhere in the New
Testament for Christians to keep the
Jewish sabbath it's not there all
references in the New Testament are
negative references to the Sabbath he
blessed and hallowed it on the seventh
day before a Jew ever existed where is
it commanded in the New Testament well
Jesus himself in Matthew 2420 about the
End of Time says pray that your flight
not be in the winter neither on the
Sabbath day Luke 23:56 it says and
rested on the Sabbath day according to
the Commandment the fourth Commandment
is just that a commandment in first John
5:3 says for this is the love of God
that we keep his Commandments and his
Commandments are not Grievous to us and
it shall come to pass that from one new
moon to another and from one Sabbath to
another shall All Flesh come to worship
before me sayeth the Lord just because
something isn't reiterated in the New
Testament doesn't mean we shouldn't keep
it from the Old Testament the New
Testament doesn't address lying with a
beast either but we still know it's a
sin we serve the Lord of the Sabbath
let's spend that day with him